[Applaudissements]
un coup roulé pour marquer la fin d'une
très longue disette
onze ans après sa dernière grande
victoire tiger woods remporte un
quinzième tournoi majeur un premier
triomphe au tournoi des maîtres depuis
2005 en symbiose avec la foule le tigre
rhji de nouveau tiger woods avait deux
coups de retard en début de journée sur
l'italien francesco molinari
le golfeur de 43 ans a réussi trois
oiselets en quatre trous sur le neuf de
retour
il a mis une pression constante son
rival italien
qui a fini par flancher et ses oies du
café le prestigieux veston vert pour la
cinquième fois sa carrière revient de
loin
depuis sa dernière victoire en trois
majeurs outre vécu un divorce ultra
médiatisé provoquée par ses infidélités
plus en mai 2010 est l'américain été
arrêté en floride endormi au volant de
sa voiture il a plaidé coupable à des
accusations de conduite avec les
facultés affaiblies
vous avez consommé un cocktail de
médicaments quelques mois plus tard le
volcan s'était opéré au dos pour la
quatrième fois et admis que son avenir
ou golf était plus qu'incertain c'est la
victoire la plus difficile de ma
carrière a dit woods qui a enlacé ses
enfants après sa victoire on boucle la
boucle a dit le golfeur
mon père était ici pour ma première
victoire en 1997 et aujourd'hui c'est
moi le père de deux enfants
cailleux rythme sans reprendre sa chasse
au record de victoires en trois majeurs
il ne lui manque plus que trois pour
rejoindre le grand jack nicklaus
quand la gagner 18 et s'en prenait à
rêver au canada montréal